je suis commandant squeeze français de
père en fils depuis 1818 nous allons
diriger les plus grandes armées du pays
des soldats capables de faire un feu de
camp avec seulement le bouchon d'un
stylo bille capable de couper du steak
haché fraîchement chasse est capable en
levant le petit doigt de se décrotter
l'oreille excellent messieurs dames le
début de la guerre commence à trop
chemin jean ping pong donc je vois
projet sartre en général new game
alors voilà comment ça se présente c'est
la phase 1 après c'est beaucoup plus
amusant on a de la thune chaque unité
coûte de la thune bon début avec des
paysans la bonne france la france de
l'agriculture la france des haricots
verts on connaît bien et là on clique
sur play y est c'est parti
ils sont là on a hero gilles sur les
bleus attendait peut-être les pluies
sous les roues je sais pas j'ai enlevé
commandant c'est pas grave nous on est
les bleus c'est sûr mais les bleus et
regarder cette position cette position
comme on les a on les change c'est un
film porno d'une écurie en ont été les
rouges
en fait on va les mettre en file
indienne technique peter pan technique
disney c'est parti à aller à lille son
profil indienne mais elle se fait pas
mes ordres atteint je pense qu'on va les
avoir à aller baiser les bleus allez les
rouges
allez les rouges on les a eus ok 3v 3 on
passe à 8 en argent dit ait dix fois
plus
j'ai établi stratégique personne n'a
jamais faire une [ __ ] de range énergie
intouchable sa mère qu'il est belle à
s'en mettre en place elle est belle au
maire de ressources en fait c'est une
file indienne
mais tirait principaux collègues devant
ok donc là la safer une vraie ligne
c'est parti je sais pas hayate c'est le
marché plus jamais brûlé brûlé tous
on va prendre les spearman son salaire
tchité ça plaît aux bains la mecque
c'est simple et c'est comme une fourche
en deux fois plus loin des voies plus
pointus allez-y oui ça opale ça en pal
c'est ça qu'on veut
pourquoi pourquoi on perd ça on parlait
bien jusque là il est tout seul mais il
appelle à choquer la versera il tient
tête
il tient tête c'est notre héros il est
là hercules et la personne peut le test
que tu as à faire
on l'appelle le yoyo il les baises un
parra il est dans son jacuzzi ils sont
dans leurs qualités à merde
ok un canon crew seul contre tous on va
bien le mettre derrière c'est parti
tu peux le faire vas-y
oh oui
[Musique]
bon là c'est chaud bon alors on appelle
mylène farmer
mylène farmer haché colonel j'ai pas dit
que j'étais maurice
le problème c'est qu'il faut laisser une
ligne entre chaque truc aulas je pensais
ça ok là on est bons amants on y va on y
va on y va aller les boucliers et
derrière les lens allez les gars comme
abaisse de déchets tous les ans pas non
les opales rien du tout seul grâce à
croiser sur un v1 sur un verre divin de
l'espace oui allez coutu l'écoutent
bouquet nova 5 août je crois en toi je
crois en toi toutes mes forces
tu peux le faire tu es un bon soldat
[Musique]
là n'évoluent pas ils fuient ça y va
prendre la fuite à l'est seuls contre
tous petits le faire la question est
terrible est crucial pour la mecque je
fais une strate de malades
je vais pas vous mentir mon père du
capitaine tout devant c'est pas pourquoi
on met un bouclier pour les perturber
c'est parti quand le mec affrontera il a
du courage là je fais un truc de malade
à et les archers elle vous visez bien
oui oui ça marche
les archers mais tu es pas d'eau pas sa
passe et ça a passé
olivier dernier il va mourir il va
mourir
il va mourir ou pas mais tu es là
mais voilà et jean michel jestin club
aixois a coulé pour lui mettre une page
se tourne et de géo c'est trop long ok
on est passé à 1 on a moins d'argent
qu'ils sont peu faire moi j'aimais bien
un petit lignée de paysans et comme
salah est derrière mettre les archers ce
parti au cvo que je refasse bomba les
flashs et laisser ça va le faire
nicolas république a donné 6 ils ont
fait un escadron d'archers dans le bac
les [ __ ] comment tuer cet escadron mais
je crois que j'ai trouvé
mais c'est la douille - avec mais tu
peux faire que ça
quand
la peur
pourquoi savent pas visé
[Musique]
bafa vous tuer ils peuvent pas vous tuer
mais les gars étaient sales acrosport
ces choix
ok ok j'étais sur la mauvaise version du
jeu une grosse merde l'inde et sur la
fin on devrait y arriver plus facilement
hockey qui se change en a 500 et une en
face ils sont deux cas de figure mais
les baisers island il ya des stats nom
est la seule contre tous il peut le
faire
ça c'était mon barbara qui a explosé dès
le début non mais si je comprends bien
ce mec qui agonise et qui rouspètent
c'était mon barbare mais heureusement
j'en ai mis un deuxième qui fait des
grandes enjambées allez vas-y tu y vas
tout seul choqué et choqué il n'a
sûrement jamais en acrosport oui comment
ils les règles il est intouchable c'est
incroyable et je parle pas du film est
comme art si c'est pas la fouille et
pourtant qui peut le stopper
et voilà je suis de retour mais capacité
augmentée mais il donnait à mais là ils
sont beaucoup il ya un chick youngman
moi je veux un tiken man fait mon
arrivée il m'a appris tout mais tu
j'espère qu'il est bon qu'est-ce qu'il
fait le tiguan man i poupe des pôles
mondiaux aux communes est dingue les
veines avec son cul excellent annonce
appadurai mec moi je veux voir un
samouraï master est lent mais de fait
nous rêver les gars mais c'est la même
animation que le barbare pour toi c'est
pas la même culture
ils sont tellement forts c'est
incroyable
oh il a fait un double quine à la fin
très très fort ils sont super en
laissant beaucoup il ya des bouquets ce
qu'on peut mettre devant un chariot
c'est quoi ça mais perdrait le foulard
et on va mettre des petits samouraïs 1
de parts et d'autres
voilà on y va
qu'est ce qui se passe plus canopy
canaux pour cette année et les samouraïs
ça donne quoi
d'accord et la catapulte tout allait
super violent lui raté va peut-être
gagner est autant à ses deux balles à la
hâte en équipage de canon c'est pas mal
ça et là on va mettre ce mec à la hache
et trois mecs qui juste cogné la tête
ou alors soit pourquoi ces foires les
canaux ou pas oh oui il m'a séduit ça y
est hall a présidé la mauvaise idée de
satom attend là c'est chaud j'ai plus de
deux canons je pense qu'ils peuvent le
faire ils tirent super vite oh oui oh
oui va gagner regardez le il sait ce qui
l'attend est là à quoi tâche est un très
très bon capital y est ta [ __ ] c'est
quoi des barrels roller à les barres
elles relâchent pas qu observer
bourguiba et ben voila et servent à rien
ces grosses merdes à 6 faut que le feu
si c'est pas mal quand même
bref c'est les catapultes au mec tu vas
te méprends de chercher désolé ça arrive
ça arrive
ouais ouais c'est quoi ça oh ça me plaît
qu'est ce que ça fait mais c'est pas mal
mais après quand ça va plus ça a plu et
vous est-ce que ça vous a plu
mais comment tu baisses ces [ __ ] de
catapult ap tête avec ça arm est tiré
c'est pas mal enfin davantage sait
qu'ils baissent leur propre cas avec
leurs boules et les autres là bas vous
pouvez le faire
eux ils esquivent eux ils sont bien là
les deux ils sont tout ouïe ouïe satire
de superbes
ça c'est fait on l'a armés de boucliers
bon et on a que 1500 bon ça va être
hyper simple c'est ma stratégie
aujourd'hui ils vont lancer des plus
avenants maison car javelot assez nul
il veut lancer le javelot puis ensuite
mecque et où il fait plus rien
maintenant les gars âge je veux bien que
vous ayez des boucliers mais quand même
là ils encaissent beaucoup agacé la
folie et javelot c'est incroyable il en
lans civile
ils peuvent plus bouger ils sont coincés
dans les lancers - là mannequin pialet
cette battle n'a aucun sens à diana
tiens c'est qu'une épée mais non tu peux
pas le rater à ses distances ma boutique
mais walla est le petit dernier là bas
non mais il va sans broncher tout seul
fait le tour fait le tour je te jure la
n'y a pas de faim qu'on tourne il va
situer à force
[Musique]
chahuté en plus des murs du 21e siècle
ok des lanciers avec des trucs bon il
faut quoi là enfin les bois aux caisses
et type par an vous attend voilà c'est
comme ça qu'on règle les problèmes ici
pour moi les gars on se dit à bientôt
ciao
on va
voilà le petit dernier voilà ça y âge
c'est quand que j'ai une étoile la 2
récompenses jean n'émarge pas des toiles
alors aulas à se la joue avec 600 cas
n'ont pas de soucis un super boxeur seul
contre tous va-t-il y arriver tu peux le
faire voler
voilà très bien s'est passé regarder mes
fusées sont en train de dominer ils ont
beaucoup jacques of duty ça leur a pris
énormément de choses sur les arbres sauf
lui et voilà c'est willy res qui fait
quoi il risque il ya personne là bas
vous faites quoi mais qu'est ce que vous
foutez qu'ici foot mais qu'est ce qu'ils
foutent
voilà c'était mon peignoir acentic
allemagne ok c'est e-barreau fait ça
avec que des instruments génieau a nommé
les canonniers sont pourris la même là
puisqu'on va alourdir son navet partie
au ciel [ __ ] je crée énormément que je
suis général ham c'est incroyable
bayonne à mes fils marc je suis désolé
exemple
bon ok j'en vois trump voilà normand
c'est fini c'est fini
on va tester les trucs qui tire de loin
ils se font du quai par des poules pour
devrait regarder
voilà les poules trop vénère c'est
parfait mais un coup de fusil dans le
cul la poule [ __ ] mais c'est gagné
c'est gagner j'ai parlé trop vite hossa
pas sur quoi là moi je vois des mecs qui
font que t-cuento taekwondo vs arme
blanche un au dos tellement beau
tellement beau c'est arrivé comme ça à
regarder
voilà les boucliers les h on s'en fout
nous ont fait chuter couanau mon gars
nous on saute on utilise les membres de
notre corps c'est très très beau plus
qu'à aller à ils sont chiants bonsoy
faire voilà l'avancé gagné l'asie contre
finalement les vikings on y va
maintenant mais les gars vous pouvez pas
mais vous pouvez pas tirer sur nos
pattes de devant à ninja il faut trop
mal mais agréable ils craignent personne
en paix syro canadiens tout en lançant
leur chéri qu'elle a l'âge c'est déjà
apprises ben alors on a du mal avec sa
hache là elle sa vieille coiffe de dours
sonné claqué bon pote et vanessa les
cerveaux de cette vidéo surtout talent
qu utilisait le nom impossible à dire
j'étais assez aux apu ces cas n'hésitez
pas à se pâmer le pouce bleus ça servira
à rien on peut cliquer qu'une fois et
moi j'adore j'adore les jaunards idol
j'adore les jeux où ceux ci c'est la
pure physique tu peux place et soldats
au même endroit je fais plein de fois
d'affilée va pas se passer les mêmes
trucs que j'aime beaucoup
voilà j'espère que ça vous a plu c'était
général squeeze dès à présent je me
démunis des fonctions tu as vu mon
étoile
voilà je la scotch ici excellence est en
fait un pot de gel rose j'ai tué des
milliers de gens ont gagné des dizaines
de guerre war socgen a laissé nul à
chier attendu prochaine vidéo portez
vous bien tu as tout le monde
[Musique]